i mentioned uh at the top of the show in
our first segment sort of taking a big
picture look at
what's going on and and the the options
the two possible paths forward that the
country is facing right now
in the wake of the riotous insurrection
from last week i talked about what's
happening within the republican party
and you have some republicans that are
bailing on donald trump
uh and you have some that are not and i
made the point that
the the people that are bailing with 11
days to go
this is not an act of courage this is an
act of self-preservation and it's really
important that we not allow these people
to rehabilitate their reputations
because they've been part of it
for a very long time and only now when
it is relatively safe politically to do
so
they are saying this is too much that's
too much much i can't be a part of it
but that being said
there is a growing list of republicans
that now want to remove
donald trump and i think it's important
to understand that this is different we
did not see this
uh during the first impeachment as it
looks like we are heading towards a
second impeachment of the president so
let's talk about it a little bit
and go through some of the instances
republican senator lisa murkowski a
sitting
senator republican from the state of
alaska
says that she wants trump out and may
even leave the republican party
altogether over this now if she does
leave she's not saying she would become
a democrat
there's every indication that if she
were to leave the republican party she
would be
an independent but she put out a
statement pointing out that donald trump
incited this mob to unlawfully breach
the capital
led to injured and in fact law
enforcement
deaths put members of congress in danger
put the vice president in danger
interfered with the duty of congress to
count the electoral votes
and she goes on to say that donald trump
indeed should leave
lisa murkowski saying i think he should
leave he said he's not going to show up
he's not going to appear at the
inauguration he hasn't been focused on
what's going on with kovid
he's either been golfing or he's been
inside the oval office fuming and
throwing
every person who's been loyal and
faithful to him under the bus starting
with the vice president
he only wants to stay there for the
title she says he only wants to stay
there for his ego
he needs to get out he needs to do the
good thing but i don't think he's
capable of doing a good thing
so an important statement from
republican lisa murkowski
she's not saying she would vote to
convict she's saying trump should leave
trump should resign and it's not clear
that there's even a one percent chance
that he does that
um and yes she also went on to say
that uh the her future may not be in the
republican party but it's not in the
democratic party either
every indication is lisa murkowski would
become an independent if she were to
leave the party but it's something
it's still a big deal another current
republican senator
pat toomey says remove trump he's
actually saying
it is time to remove donald trump take a
listen to what he had to say yesterday
on
one of the sunday shows your republican
colleague senator lisa murkowski of
alaska says president trump should
resign
she said uh quote he's caused enough
damage
do you agree yeah i do
uh i i think at this point with just a
few days left
it's um the best path forward the best
way to
get this person in the rearview mirror
uh for us
uh that could happen immediately i'm not
optimistic it will
but uh i do think that would be the best
way forward so that is a big deal
that it that that that is huge there's
no way around that
yes we're down to nine days left but
that is still uh uh
you know it's starting to point to what
we had you know when richard nixon
uh was about to be impeached republicans
got together and they went to him and
they said this is it
this is it you we you're getting
impeached and we're going to convict
um and at that time circumstances were
very different and it's
it's almost cliche and overly simplistic
to say republicans then were willing to
do what republicans today aren't willing
to do
the republican party is also
dramatically more radical today
than it was um i think that today's
republican party also
wouldn't have said to nixon it's time to
go unfortunately
but that was when there was something
that was beyond the line today nothing
seems to be beyond the line for most
republicans so
good for pat toomey however he then says
in the same interview that that voting
for trump made sense at the time
after wednesday's attack you took to the
senate floor to denounce president trump
as a demagogue
but we should note you voted for him in
november for the second time even after
charlottesville right even after he used
force to clear
lafayette square for a photo op even
after he embraced q anon conspiracy
theorists many of whom were in that mob
i'm not saying you bear any
responsibility for what happened
on wednesday but do you regret not doing
more
to stop somebody you're not now calling
a demagogue
who's pretty obviously been a demagogue
for his entire political career
yeah jake i don't think there's any
doubt at all there's none in my mind
that the president's behavior after the
election was
wildly different than his behavior
before he descended into a level of
madness
and engaged in activity that was just
absolutely unthinkable and unforgivable
for four years he often put out
offensive and objectionable tweets
actually sometimes dozens a day i never
felt and i still don't think that my job
was to be his
the editor of his twitter feed although
i was very often
critical so you can see the direction
that that's that's going right i mean
these are pathetic defenses
if we all knew what the direction of
trump's presidency
was going to be why couldn't they know
we knew in 2016 when trump was elected
that this was going to become an
authoritarian nightmare
and pat toomey says well you know other
than the mean tweets it all seemed
perfectly reasonable at the time no
and this is why i'm saying a lot of
these guys are doing this just out of
self-pressure preservation
and then lastly long-time trump loyalist
chris christie
says if inciting to insurrection isn't
impeachment worthy
then i really don't know what is now but
if an impeachment resolution actually
comes to the floor
won't many republicans be hard-pressed
to oppose it
listen i think they're all going to have
to vote their conscience and
and look at what happened i mean what we
had was an incitement
to riot at the united states capital we
had people killed
uh and to me there's not a whole lot of
question here
so you know so you think it was an
impeachable offense before jordan
oh sure yeah and you'd vote to i think
that
you know in the well that's if i think
it's an impeachable offense that's
exactly what i would do george but i'm
i'm not in there
but you want my opinion that's my
opinion i i don't i think if
if inciting to insurrection isn't then i
don't really know what is
um but i will say too that the democrats
by what they did earlier on ukraine have
kind of cheapened this a little bit too
so you know there there's always a hedge
and chris christie says democrats
cheapened impeachment with ukraine
but yeah he should be impeached this
time that's
a big time trump loyalist that's a
powerful republican figure
that's a guy who was metaphorically and
literally behind donald trump for years
standing on stage sometimes looking a
little sick from the thing
things trump was saying but it's a big
deal that chris christie now says yes
this is absolutely impeachable so
there's no sympathy for any of these
republican operatives they were behind
trump
for years but it is important that it's
also republicans this time too
not because we need to allow their image
to be rehabilitated
but because it confirms to us how bad
things are that even with the most
radical republican party we've arguably
ever had
we are starting to see some republicans
say it's time to go yeah it's pathetic
it's only nine days to go
i get it they they don't get anything
other than
this does signal how insane the
situation has gotten but one guy
who i guess is going down with the ship
is republican senator lindsey graham and
i want to talk about him next
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks s h masks has everything you
need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear for
covid19 and they're giving my audience
20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks
and shipping is free on orders over a
hundred and fifty dollars
you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save twenty percent on
everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david